[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen Handball
natürlich und mehr sehen Sie im Sport
mit Norbert Lehmann einen schönen guten
Abend auch von mir und Sie können sich
schon mal darauf einstellen dass
Bahnfahren diese Woche schwierig
wird sech Tage Streik ab Mitte der Woche
will die lockführergewerkschaft GDL den
Bahnverkehr lahm legen solangee wie noch
nie Deutschland hat einen Staatsmann
verloren Europa hat eine Säule verloren
beim Staatsakt für Wolfgang Schäuble
ehren ihn Frankreichs Präsident macron
und weitere Politiker als großen
Demokraten und deutsches Team unter
Druck die DHB Auswahl will in der Partie
gegen Ungarn heute Fehler vermeiden und
auf siegpiel um das Halbfinale zu
erreichen die GDL ruft zum längsten
Streik in der Geschichte der Deutschen
Bahn auf denn die lockführergewerkschaft
hält nichts vom neuen Tarifangebot der
Bahn die Bahn wirft der GDL wiederum vor
maßlos den Konflikt zu verschärfen der
GDL Streik im Personenverkehr soll am
Mittwoch um 2 Uhr beginnen und bis
Montag um 18 Uhr dauern das wären 136
Stunden im Güterverkehr soll der Streik
bereits morgenabend an anfangen und dann
auch am Montag um 18 Uhr enden Stefanie
Hein
berichtet es werden nur wenige Züge
unterwegs sein wenn die Lockführer
streiken Reaktionen vom Berliner
Hauptbahnhof ich verstehe es dass man
streikt aber ist natürlich jetzt für die
normale Gesellschaft die viel mit der
baufäht ist natürlich schwierig wenn man
zur Arbeit muss und so weiter aber nicht
hinkommt ja die sollten auch ein
bisschen kompromissbereiter sein und vor
allen Dingen auch mal schauen dass
andere Bevölkerungsschichten ja auch
nicht alles durchsetzen können was sie
gerne hätten die GDL fordert eine 35
Stunden Woche für Schichtarbeiter bei
vollem Lohnausgleich die Bahn bietet 37
Stunden an oder 2,7% mehr Geld
zusätzlich bei 38 Stunden Arbeit die
Reduzierung aber nur wenn es genügend
Personal in den Zügen gibt die
Gewerkschaft will auch über
fahrdienstleitung und
instandhaltungsbetriebe verhandeln das
Angebot von Bahnvorstand Martin Seiler
sei tricksen und
Täuschen verhandeln wird die GD
wenn klar ist dass Herr Seiler keine
Vorbedingung stellt und nicht die
vorgäste und auch seine eigenen Kollegin
und Kollegen veralbert wenn klar ist
dass dieser Bahnvorstand mit uns in
Verhandlung Eintritt über alle Elemente
die wir gefordert haben der Chef der
Deutschen Bahn fordert
Kompromissbereitschaft statt endlich zu
verhandeln stürzt sich die GDL in den
nächsten langen Streik unter dem das
ganze Land leidet die GDL schärft den
Konflikt und setzt aktuell alles
ausschließlich auf Eskalation der
Bundesverkehrsminister will sich nicht
direkt einmischen mahnt aber zur
Mäßigung die Tarifverhandlungen haben
zunehmend destruktive Züge glaube nicht
dass Herr wesselski sich und seiner
Gewerkschaft damit einen Gefallen tut
man muss am Verhandlungstisch sitzen und
Kompromisse ausarbeiten in einer solchen
Situation anders als beim letzten Mal
will die Deutsche Bahn diese Woche nicht
versuchen gerichtlich gegen die Streiks
vorzugehen
wenn Sie wissen möchten worauf sie als
Reisende während des Streiks achten
müssen mit unserer ZDF heute App halten
wir Sie auf dem Laufenden und
informieren z.B über notfahrpläne
umbuchungen und
Entschädigungen das Deutschland Ticket
soll in diesem Jahr weiterhin 49 € pro
Monat kosten das haben die
Verkehrsministerin und Minister der
Länder beschlossen bis zum Ende des
Jahres sei die Finanzierung gesichert
Bund und Länder tragen die Kosten wie
bisher gemein
der Bund hat dafür 1,5 Milliarden Euro
eingeplant wie es im nächsten Jahr
weitergeht ist noch
offen auch heute demonstrieren wieder
tausende gegen Rechtsextremismus zur
Stunde etwa in Freiberg in Sachsen
Greifswald sost Paderborn am Wochenende
waren es nach Angaben der Polizei mehr
als 100.000 am Reichstag in Berlin
ebenso viele in München am Siegestor am
Kölner Rheinufer
70.000 insgesamt 910 000 Stimmen gegen
Rechtsextremismus wie das politische
Berlin reagiert dazu Karl Hinterleitner
das politische Berlin zeigt sich heute
beeindruckt von den Kundgebungen und
reagiert mit Dank an die Demonstranten
aber auch mit Nachdenklichkeit das gut
dass die Zivilgesellschaft die Straße
geht das ist ein großes Momentum aber
natürlich auch ein Auftrag an uns dass
wir Vertrauen zurückgewinnen also dass
wir bessere Politik machen das heißt für
mich dass wir dafür sorgen dass es
gerecht zugeht in die diesem Land dass
alle Menschen sich darauf verlassen
können dass sie von ihrer Arbeit leben
können bessere Regierungspolitik eine
Forderung die sogar aus den eigenen
Reihen kommt die Kommunikation der Ampel
sei schlecht vor allem außerhalb der
Großstädte fühle man sich von Berlin
vernachlässigt das heizungsgesetz hat
viel viel Unmut gebracht vor allem auch
im ländlichen Raum und jetzt auch
natürlich einfach den Bauern die
Subvention zu kürzen das ist alles kein
Grund und keine Rechtfertigung AFD zu
wählen aber wir müssen ja offen darüber
sprechen woher auch die Stimmung kommt
auch die CDU meint auf die
Herausforderung von rechts müsse man
inhaltlich reagieren also ich halte es
für ganz wichtig dass wir die AFD vor
allen Dinge mit politischen Mitteln
bekämpfen dass wir sie auch in der Sache
stellen dass wir auch sagen was die
Folgen dieser Politik wären und da muss
man nur mal ins Programm schauen um zu
sehen dass die AFD gegen die NATO ist
gegen die Europäische Union ist mit
allen Voraussetzungen und Folgen die
damit Verbund wen ein Rezept gegen
Extremismus habe letztlich niemand es
Hile nur die politische
Auseinandersetzung ja die
Demonstrierenden fordern auf jeden Fall
ein härteres Vorgehen gegen die AFD
shakunta la Beni in der Politik wird
jetzt die jüngste Idee diskutiert ob der
AFD die staatlichen Zuschüsse gestrichen
werden können worum geht's da genau ja
da geht's eben nicht um die politische
Auseinandersetzung sondern um ein
mögliches juristisches Mittel gegen die
AFD das jetzt hier ins Gespräch kommt
seit 2017 sieht das Grundgesetz in einem
Artikel die Möglichkeit vor einer Partei
die verfassungsfeindliche Ziele verfolgt
äh die staatlichen Zuschüsse zu
entziehen und laut darüber nachgedacht
haben unter anderem schon Markus Söder
Bayerns Ministerpräsident aber auch aus
der SPD und von den Grünen kommen heute
Stimmen die sagen diesen Weg solle man
sich anschauen skeptischer sieht es
offensichtlich die CDU Torsten frei den
wir auch gerade im Beitrag schon gesehen
haben sagt schon das Gedankenspiel könne
weitere Stimmen für die AFD mobilisieren
und auch der Ausschluss von der
Parteienfinanzierung der sehr hohe
juristische Hörden vor die müssten dann
vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht geprüft werden
also da hat er doch erhebliche Zweifel
wie hoch diese Hörden tatsächlich sind
das könnte sich morgen schon zeigen da
wird nämlich das
Bundesverfassungsgericht
Urteilen über einen Antrag von 2019 da
haben Bundesrat Bundestag und
Bundesregierung gemeinsam gegen die NPD
einen Antrag eingereicht auf
achluss von der Parteienfinanzierung und
je nachdem wie das Urteil morgen
aussieht wird sich die Debatte dann
vielleicht noch weiterentwickeln Markus
Söder jedenfalls hat schon einmal gesagt
das Urteil könne eine Blaupause sein für
den Umgang mit der AFD vielen Dank
schunal
Beni Gedenken an Wolfgang Schäuble im
Berliner Dom gab es heute ihm zu Ehren
einen Gottesdienst im Bundestag wurde
Wolfgang Schäuble mit einem
trauerstaatsakt gewürdigt mit dabei die
höchsten äsentantinnen und
Repräsentanten des Staates sowie der
französische Präsident der frühere
Bundestagspräsident Schäuble war am 26
dezember im Alter von 81 Jahren
gestorben Andreas
[Musik]
hert Abschied von einem überzeugten
Parlamentarier der Bundestag trauert um
Wolfgang Schäuble das Gremium dem er
über ein halbes Jahrhundert angehört hat
solange wie keine oder keiner jemals zu
Wolfgang Schäuble war der vollendete
Staatsdiener immer galt für ihn erst das
Amt dann die
Person zum Schluss war er zu einer
Instanz geworden über Parteigrenzen
hinweg ob als Bundestagspräsident als
Fraktionschef oder als einfacher
Abgeordneter Wolfgang Schäuble hat den
Parlamentarismus in Deutschland
mitgeprägt als Bundesinnenminister wirde
zum Architekten der deutschen Einheit
Schäubles Meisterstück zuur allkanzlerin
Merkel im ZDF Interview und dann war er
in den Kabinetten den er angehörte
einfach ein Anker von Stabilität von
Ruhe und intellektuellem Scharfsinn und
dann gibt es so etwas wie einen
dreiklank seines größeren politischen
Vermächtnisses dieser dreiklank lautet
deutsche Einheit Berlin Europa an diesen
überzeugten Europäer Schäuble erinnert
Frankreichs Präsident macron in seiner
Trauerrede die er zu großen Teilen auf
deutsch
Deutschland hat einen Staatsmann
verloren Europa hat eine Säule
verloren frankreich hat einen fr
verloren auf den Tag genau heute vor 61
Jahren unterzeichnen Frankreich und
Deutschland den eliseevertrag bekunden
ihre Freundschaft und legen den
Grundstein für das Friedensprojekt
Europa ein Projekt dem sich Wolfgang
Schäuble verpflichtet sah zum Abschluss
der Trauerfeier die nationalhümne zu
Ehren eines überzeugten Europäers und
[Musik]
Demokraten die Europäische Union
versuchte im Nahen Osten zu vermitteln
so waren zum Treffen der EU
Außenministerin und Minister auch der
israelische sowie der palästinensische
Außenminister eingeladen die EU erhöht
dabei den Druck einer zwei staatenlösung
zuzustimmen Israel könne Frieden Zitat
nicht nur mit militärischen Mitteln
erreichen
s agte EU chefdipomat Borell aus Brüssel
Florian
neuhn es kommen heute nach Brüssel der
Außenminister aus Israel und der der
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde sie
kommen nacheinander ohne Risiko an der
Begegnung und ohne Aussicht auf
Annäherung an jedem Tag in dem wir
weiter zögern werden Menschen getötet
unschuldige Menschen Kinder Frauen alte
das ist unerträglich und
inakzeptabel
unsere mutigen Soldaten kämpfen weiter
unter sehr harten Bedingungen für diese
zwei Ziele die Geiseln
zurückzubringen und die Sicherheit für
die Bürger Israels
wiederherzustellen Europa drängt auf
eine Zweistaatenlösung im Nahen Osten
soll heißen die Gründung eines neuen
palästinensischen Staates auch wenn
israels Regierung darüber zum ärgerfer
nicht einmal reden will israel kann nur
in Sicherheit leben wenn Palästinenser
in Sicherheit in Würde leben können
deswegen ist die zwei staatenlösung die
einzige Lösung der Weg dahin noch weit
nicht so weit dagegen bis zu einem neuen
EU Militäreinsatz im Roten Meer um
Handelsschiffe zu schützen am Abend
meldet der
Außenbeauftragte wir haben uns im
Grundsatz auf eine Marine Operation im
Roten Meer verständigt und die
verschiedenention er Mission
diskutiert parallel dazu will Europa
eine Friedenskonferenz für den Nahen
Osten vorbereiten auf der sich die
Außenminister aus der Region irgendwann
gar
begegnen das Rennen um die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur der
US-Republikaner hat kurz vor der
nächsten Vorwahl in New Hampshire einen
Bewerber weniger Ron desenttis beendet
seine Kampagne der Gouverneur von
Florida gab bekannt dass er nun
Expräsident Trump unterstütze dabei
hatte der ihn bis zuletzt verunglimpft
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Nicki haey
die letzte republikanische Bewerberin
Donald Trump noch ausbremsen kann gilt
als
gering Malaria gilt als eine der
tödlichsten Krankheiten für Kinder in
Afrika jährlich sterben daran mehr als
500.000 Menschen vor allem Kinder unter
5 Jahren Kamerun hat jetzt das weltweit
erste Impfprogramm gegen die
Tropenkrankheit
gestartet en ist eine vierfachimpfung
von Babys und Kleinkindern obwohl die
Wirksamkeit bislang bei nur 30 bis 50%
liege könne die großflächige Kampagne
laut Fachleuten dazu beitragen dass
weniger Kinder an Malaria
sterben
Umerziehung auch das ist eine Waffe
Russlands im Krieg gegen die Ukraine
Kinder werden aus besetzten Gebieten
verschleppt und russischer Propaganda
ausgesetzt ihre ukrainische Identität
sollen sie vergessen
heute ist das auch Thema beim un
kinderrechtsausschuss in Genf
ukrainischen Hilfsorganisation gelingt
es immer wieder Kinder und Jugendliche
zurückzuholen Anne Bröhl hat in Kiev mit
einem dieser Heimkehrer sprechen können
alle sollen wissen was die Russen
gemacht haben sagt uns rostislav als wir
ihn in Kiev treffen er lebt jetzt in
einer Einrichtung für verschleppte
Kinder und Jugendliche rostislav ist
halbweise war 16 als die Russen sein
Dorf beion besetzten seine Mutter in die
Psychiatrie steckten und ihn einfach
mitnahmen auf die
Krim das Lager hatte den Namen drusba
Freundschaft dort sollten wir jeden Tag
mit der russischen Hymne Aufstehen die
russische Flagge hisen und russische
Lieder
singen weil er nicht mitmachen wollte
musste er immer wieder in die
Arrestzelle
viermal sie haben mich beschimpft sie
haben gesagt dass es die Ukraine nicht
mehr gibt D und Odessa zu Russland
der Weg in die Freiheit gelingt nur
wenigen und soll geheim bleiben denn
noch immer werden rund 19000 Kinder von
den Russen festgehalten die ukrainischen
Behörden wollen dass die Täter zur
Verantwortung gezogen
werden das ist vor allem eine Frage der
Gerechtigkeit und dann auch eine
Prävention für die Zukunft wenn der
Aggressor versteht dass es keine
Verantwortung gibt was tut er dann er
macht weiter er ne
Verbrechen R fühlt sich wohl in Kiev
fotografiert gerne macht
Pläne ich möchte dass der Krieg zu Ende
ist und was meine Zukunft betrifft so
will ich Weiterlernen ich will entweder
Programmierer oder Fotograf
werden und irgendwann sagt er will er
auch zurück in sein Dorf ob seine Mutter
noch lebt weiß er
nicht und wir blicken jetzt nach Indien
den da wurde jetzt mit einer riesigen
Inszenierung ein umstrittener
Hindutempel eingeweiht vor tausenden
geladenen Gästen vom indischen
Premierminister Modi persönlich
Millionen verfolgenten das Ganze vor dem
Fernseher der Tempel wurde auf einem
Gelände gebaut auf dem früher eine
historische Moschee stand die von
radikalen Hindus zerstört wurde Johannes
hanno
berichtet es ist ein Tag der in die
Geschichtsbücher Indiens eingehen wird
da sind sich viele hier sicher auch
Indiens Premierminister Narendra
Modi heute in diesem besonderen Moment
legen wir den Grundstein für das Indien
der nächsten 1us Jahre mit dem Bau
dieses Tempels versprechen wir ein
großes göttliches Indien zu
erschaffen ein Versprechen für die
nächsten 1000 Jahre vor 7000 geladenen
Gästen Gurus Politikern
Wirtschaftsmagnaten und Bollywood Stars
inszeniert sich Modi als Führer und
Schutzpatron V allem der hindumehrheit
im Land von vielen verehrt fast selbst
wie ein
Gott Modi hat wundervoll brachte wir in
J neues Himmelsreich erschaffen dröhnt
es aus seinem
Megaphon wenn Modi bleibt dann wird
alles gut für unser Land und die
Gesellschaft meint
er dort wo jetzt der Hindutempel steht
stand zuvor seit dem 16 Jahrhundert eine
Moschee 192 wurde die von einem Hindu
Mob gestürmt und zerstört Indien stehe
heute an einem Weg meint Modis
Biograf werden wir ein theokratischer
Staat oder nicht werden wir ein Staat in
die Minderheiten auch religiöse
Minderheiten marginalisiert und ihre
Rechte mit Füßen getreten werden um das
passiert oder nicht wird sich bei den
Parlamentswahlen im Frühling 2024
entscheiden
egal aber wie die Wahl ausgeht mit dem
rahtempel hat sich Modi selbst ein
Denkmal
gesetzt
75 Minuten noch dann ist es soweit
Anwurf bei der handballem Deutschland
gegen Ungarn und da muss das DHB Team
gewinnen EBO das letzte Hauptrundenspiel
am Mittwoch gegen Kroatien um die
halbfinalchance zu wahren nach dem
schwachen Remis gegen Österreich braucht
es heute eine klare
Leistungssteigerung auch Bundestrainer
Alfred gielerson macht mit beim
anschwitzen im Teamhotel um im Bilde zu
bleiben es bedarf ganz sicher einer
Kraftanstrengung gegen Ungarn um die
Chance aufs Halbfinale zu waren noch so
einen schwachen Auftritt wie gegen
Österreich kann und darf sich das
dhbteam nicht erlauben einer der bisher
immer seine Leistung gezeigt hat bei
dieser EM Andreas Wolf vorgestern allein
drei gehaltene 7 m damit es auch gleich
im dritten Hauptrundenspiel klappt
erhält wohf von Torwarttrainer Anderson
wertvolle Informationen über die
Wurfvarianten der ungarischen
Offensive ja Jörg Polus in Köln also
hinten top aber der deutsche Angriff der
muss viel viel besser
werden ja Norbert daran gibt es
überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel
Bundestrainer Alfred gissl und selbst
hat von einer indiskutablen von einer
grausamen Angriffsleistung seiner
Mannschaft gegen Österreich gesprochen
und das muss natürlich besser werden die
Mannschaft hat sich vollkommen
zurückgezogen abgeschottet volle
Konzentration auf die heutige Aufgabe
gegen Ungarn und so ist das Team heute
unter dem Motto zurück zu alter Stärke
in Köln an der Halle angekommen
allerdings fehlte einer timo kastening
ist nicht dabei hat ein Virusinfekt er
kann der Mannschaft heute nicht helfen
und dafür ist Lukas Zerbe aus Lemgo
nachbeordert worden ob der allerdings
pünktlich hier in Köln erscheinen wird
da sind wir mal gespannt in gut einer
Stunde wird's ernst hier in Köln gegen
Ungarn bei uns im ZDF live ab 20:15 uh
danke Jork bis gleich zu den Australian
Open da hat Alexander SF das
Viertelfinale erreicht fünfsatzsieg in
einem hartumkämpften Match gegen Cameron
nor befreiter Jubel nach mehr als vi
Stunden harter Arbeit er hat den Briten
viermal klar geschlagen diesmal wird in
den fünften Satz gezwungen und
schließlich in den Tiebreak dort jedoch
ein souveräner Deutscher und ein
nervöser
Gegner der marathonman Alexander SF
zieht am Geburtstag seines Vaters ins
Viertelfinale ein ja der H mir am Ende
des Tages gesagt du hätest auch mal ein
dreisätzen gewinnen können d h wir mal
geburtstagieren können nächster Gegner
der an zwei gesetzte Spanier Carlos
alcas ja und das letzte Duell der beiden
im November das hat zwerff geworden
yay beim Wetter wird es vorübergehend
etwas ruhiger mehr dazu gleich von
östtin terle in der Halbzeitpause der
Handball EM Hauptrunde Deutschland gegen
Ungarn können Sie das heute journal mit
Christian Siebers sehen gegen 21:10 Uhr
machen sie es
[Musik]
gut
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter im zweagesabstand
kommen nun die Sturmtiefs durchgezogen
das aktuelle Sturmtief verzieht sich
allmählich und nimmt seine Kaltfront mit
dahinter kommt aber kühlere Luft und da
Ben sich Schauer und einzelne Gewitter
dazwischen gibt's morgen sogar mal
trockene Abschnitte bevor hier die
nächste Warmfront kommt und neuen Regen
mitbringt das zur Übersicht in der Nacht
gibt es einzelne Gewitter und zahlreiche
Schauer in den höheren Lagen Schnee und
Richtung Nordsee ist es sehr windig
teils mit sturmböhen und das bei
Temperaturen von -1° an den Alpen und 5°
z.B ganz im Westen morgen dann erst
einmal einige Schauer die lassen dann
rasch nach in der Mitte lockert auf hier
und da die Sonne kommt dann hervor von
Westen her kündigt sich die Warmfront an
und zum frühen Abend kommt Regen auf bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 4 bis 9° ja
und die nächsten Tage es wird wieder
stürmisch am Mittwoch mit viel Regen und
teilweise sturmböhen 8 bis 14°
Donnerstag vorübergehend Beruhigung mit
Regen und Freitag wieder windig und
schon wieder Regen schönen Abend